the Joe Rogan experience they must have
some type of like like like NDA with
extraterrestrials where they don't talk
yeah I feel like the US government or
just governments in general throughout
the world have some type of NDA TAS will
kill you I don't know how we're always
the same when Leonardo DiCaprio uses on
his girlfriend if he's got the greatest
Indian history thinking for now holy
[ __ ] no one gives a [ __ ] about India no
so we had pay people and they don't care
they'll come out and talk about it later
they had a love Lisa Ann on it on a
podcast right I just parked a horn star
yeah flagrant two right and Lisa Ann
came on and she was talking about NDA's
and how stupid women are for obeying
them and I was like what are you talking
about and she's like what do they have
to lose they don't have any money
exactly so she's like you have a bunch
of [ __ ] heels in your apartment you
think that Leonardo DiCaprio is gonna
take your heels you could break any
[ __ ] NDA but for whatever reason they
get scared you pay a woman half a
million dollars tell her to keep her
mouth closed she breaks the NDA in an da
it says she has to pay you back exactly
we don't have money forever what money
everyone is Bill O'Reilly he had to pay
a lady thirty two million dollars I mean
there's no [ __ ] worth it I need to see
what she looks like
can we look at this woman some wild [ __ ]
oh there's no picture of this woman I
don't I need to see thirty two million
dollars on blast but either loves you I
would love to see what she looks like
thirty two million he agreed to it he
must've did something he didn't want
nobody be even remotely here's gonna
pegged bill get packed 100% yet if it's
not even about what actually happened is
about what the person said they did to
you that can ruin your reputation
she's got pics she's got video
something's going and guaranteed DNA
she's got his [ __ ] under her thumb nail
like guarantee and then a guy like Bill
has to keep a certain like I guess you
know standard about himself right you
have to look at him a certain way in
order to listen to what do you think yes
in order to take his his information
you know correctly I guess seriously
yeah yeah yeah so he could lose all that
equity in his audience
watch you actually didn't help him he's
gone anyway
is it over for bill well he's not on fox
news anymore
he's podcast he was the number one guy
and they were like not worth it
yeah man y'all be talking about cancel
coach never really got canceled yeah
Ralph came over in a big way
yeah and I think he does do some type of
broadcasting now but nobody cares well
he let out a book and the book was
number one New York Times bestsellers
box yeah it doesn't history books yes
you know like I don't even think he
writes him I think he just puts his name
I wonder about a guy like bill doe
because think about it like you started
your own platform you know I'm saying
and people really care about your voice
did people ever really care about Bill
that's the thing people do now but check
it right so it's like sometimes you
become a mouthpiece for a network or for
an ideology they believe in and this is
the difference this how you find out if
people really [ __ ] with you the second
you leave that network it's like when
people leave your SPN and you never hear
about them again is like oh you thought
you were bigger than ESPN Deportes they
just want you to say strike wall that's
it yeah so I think we learned that bill
really didn't have all that cachet that
we thought we had yeah that's why I like
yes man is good analogy that's why you
got to get people I skip bayless props
yes you gotta give Janelle Hill props so
they can go other places and we'll still
care about what they have to say even if
it's just in tweets right I don't even
know what Bill O'Reilly's twitter handle
is I imagine something around like
Delaware I'm sure it is but you know I
see him he's never known for like Oh
Bill O'Reilly said this on social media
when the last time you heard Bill
O'Reilly say so might not even be I made
some news yeah he may might not even be
on stuff bro yeah he's podcasting from
his like apartment or something dude is
there's no background nothing really
yeah it's bad he's not even wearing like
suits it's got like a massive welcome
shirt it's Bill o Rogan
well we gotta look him up we got to see
the girl he [ __ ] at him and see how
they're living thank you guys like that
they say we'll just lay low for a couple
years and then someone will scoop you up
again
now there's only one Fox and when Fox
lets you go yeah if you're one of those
guys those neocon guys like you don't
really have any place else to go
hey he's too old to really understand
the landscape of like how to navigate
this new internet space you've got
plenty of conservative voices who don't
have those big platforms right
the Candace on Tommy Lauren's [ __ ]
Bureau look at them Wow no makeup really
look at the he's wearing a nurse's
outfit underneath the no pants on for
sure guarantee that's adorable shirt for
real did that should take his wardrobes
go no this is not good those are nose
watch the film fold no spin news
no body low Riley dot-com oh no we need
to get some Twitter there are no charges
you are presumed innocent in this file
tree this is not what the left wants
what is this about wasn't rant about if
April 19 maybe we will report and scroll
down how many people were watching that
how many people have him on Twitter how
many how many followers do you know your
father was he had in that video had 581
thousand views can you look at him right
there in that video right now go down
now scroll down do you think he's doing
the orange thing to reflect reverse on
he's bringing him in right look at that
that's 100% the orange thing HAP's he
looks like turmeric yeah but he don't
look anything like you look some real
life that's like an Instagram ho
wait a minute not update your picture
son watching he's doing 500,000 views
yeah definitely watching it but now he's
in the vacuum but it's those crazy old
white people that live in Kansas yes
they don't happy Witter
hey man a win is a win yeah I'm saying
if you got five hundred and eighty
thousand people I can watch when you put
up a video and you can still get paid
for it I'm cool with that's true you
don't say I think we put too much
emphasis on like whatever mainstream it
is no there's no such thing as manage
people there's not just one scream
anymore
[Applause]